Marvel characters have been around for
so long at this point with minimal
reboots that you can almost trace the
daily life of any random character over
the course of several years in universe
this is a blessing and a curse in that
these characters persist so long that
you feel like you can really get to know
them but you also have a harder time
letting go of the times when their
characters are broken or drastically
changed long-form comics storytelling
has a sort of status quo that's very
hard to change or manipulate aside from
smaller details here and there most of
our favorite four-color comic characters
are doing pretty much the same thing
they were doing nearly a century ago
because that's what fans expect of them
spider-man's still a young nobody with
money problems and girl troubles
Batman's still a billionaire sad man who
collects lonely children and trains them
to punch and Superman is still working
at the Daily Planet sure they branched
off and did completely different stuff
like getting married having their secret
identities go public and die but it
doesn't really stick because they're too
popular to change now but I'm not
talking about them I'm talking about the
spider-man villain no writer seems to
know what to do with the lizard or more
specifically how the character has been
narratively frozen for nearly 60 years
unable to make any substantial character
progress like some of his counterparts
it may be along the way we can figure
out why certain comic characters have
such a hard time getting any true
development and end up spinning their
wheels forever with repetitive stories
and arcs that never go anywhere this
video topic was picked for the $100 tier
on my patreon by Kristian Callum this is
a weirdly specific video topic that I'm
not sure will have an audience but after
a long time pondering it I think it
could be interesting to discuss one of
Spidey's oldest foes and how in a
broader sense comics are almost
universally unchanging so let's give it
a try the lizard is a scientist by the
name of Curt Connors a brilliant
geneticist who lost his arm while
serving in the military or in a car
accident or a lawnmower mishap or
something studying the way some lizards
regrow lost appendages he injects
himself with a serum that restores his
arm
and turns him into a giant monster that
eats people and tries to destroy a
society but making people in the
lizard's he's most well-known for his
role as the main villain in that movie
where Andrew Garfield stutters and looks
hot and you may remember his brief
cameos in those other movies where Tobey
Maguire mumbles and has the Jack 'test
ABS you ever done seen but I personally
prefer the classic portrayal of him by
Rob Zombie look it up that's real Parker
what the hell are you doing he's one of
Spidey's oldest and most recognizable
villains due in no small part to the
fact that every cartoon or game series
takes a shot at adapting him as such
he's one of the ones that stuck around
the longest because Stan and Steve were
on a hot streak and just couldn't seem
to come up with a bad villain at the
time creating this wave of memorable
characters that people can't get enough
of
except maybe mental strong but whatever
his characterization over the years has
remained pretty consistent portraying
him as a Jacqueline Hyde archetype
brilliant scientists just trying to keep
his life together giant monster that
wrecked [ __ ] and tries to destroy
society my biggest issue with that
characterization overall is that he's
just really similar to like he has the
same conflicts and trait he's the Hulk
he's just the Hulk
split personality permanent involuntary
changes damaged personal relationships
the whole nine yards which is fine
because that's like a cool character and
he's more of a recurring side character
than like the main protagonist of
anything but over the years there's only
so much you can do with that setup for a
villain first he's cured then he's not
then his family leaves him then they're
back then he can control it then he
can't again just round and round with
that status quo he never really gets
anywhere which is also fine because I
guess life can be like that for some
people the frustration with the lizard
comes from when a good rider tries to
shake things up completely annihilates
the status quo and does something really
interesting then it doesn't take and
Paul Jenkins is awesome spectacular
spider-man run he made strides to really
reinvent Spidey villains and try new
things
he arguably created the idea that
shocker is a bumbling comic relief guy
that's just down on his luck
which other writers have adopted and
added to since then he tried to fix
Venom's busted ass character motivations
by give
a better reason for Eddie hating
spider-man which was the suit being the
only thing keeping his terminal cancer
from killing him and he had to just keep
feeding the symbiote his hate so
wouldn't abandon him and let him die
oh that other I was retconned come on
Donny that was a good one oh you know I
can't stay mad at you sweet prince that
carnage event made up for it hell this
run even had Spidey and Green Goblin
sharing calm moment or two and making a
truce lots of new ideas for character
dynamics Paul Jenkins also took a stab
at rebuilding dr. Connors in the lizard
in a lizard's tail where we find Kurt
struggling to make ends meet after his
wife's death due to sickness from
industrial pollution in that one comic
that ever on memes on for the reboot art
style
it's sad that that comic looks the way
it does because the story is actually
pretty good if you can tolerate the art
anyway doc tries to get a research grant
to get his life as a single dad back on
track but a rival scientist takes home
the prize instead then Kurt turns into a
giant scaly monster and attempts to
murder him Spidey swings in and stops
him takes him to a safe place and for
some reason Kurt knows Peters identity
like this was never established anywhere
he just does now alright I guess he goes
on this long spiel about how hard it is
being trapped in the body of a monster
and not having control himself and how
it's also somewhat freeing to just be a
dumb lizard later in the story Peter
tells Kurt some distressing news about
the press having images of Kurt
transforming though his face is
invisible
this sends Kurt into a rage where he
transforms and then for some reason this
is played like a big reveal the recap
page for the next issue says this
transformation seems deliberate but I
didn't get that vibe at all he starts
changing when he gets terrible news and
passes out in a pool of water while he's
so weak he can't finish saying a
sentence to Peter and then Peters like
it was you all along and now lizards
character is permanently tainted the
implication now is that his mental
faculties don't go away when he's the
lizard
he doesn't swap out into a separate
personality the change is purely
physical and he's been faking it the
entire time for years
he pretends to be a mindless monster
with crazy plans and an insatiable
bloodlust there's a good 20 or so
stories that make no sense now but hey
it's character development the cycle of
repetition is over this was an even
bigger change than killing off his wife
Martha her death had potential but I
could foresee all that changing is that
now no one's there to wait in the house
with Billy Connors while Spidey wrangles
the Beast for the up tenth time it's one
of those inconsequential character
changes like carnage getting a new
symbiote from the negative zone or
vulture having cancer it ultimately
changes nothing because the situation's
and character motivations are generally
the same it's just a cliff note in the
Wikipedia article or a linked list after
being confronted with the truth that
Kurt is just mentally ill and uses the
lizard as a big excuse to act out and
cause chaos when he's depressed Kirk
decides to get himself locked up michael
scofield style and stay in prison where
the world's safe from his [ __ ] it's
not the best thought-out retcon jenkins
made in his run or is it even the most
entertaining but it's an interesting
take then less
he made the lizard less of a stereotype
and opened the door for so many new
stories you could tell with that villain
the status quo was changed soon after a
lizard shows up again in Marvel Knights
spider-man number 7 and he's just a big
dumb animal and Spidey beats him up into
pages then he returns in another book
Ray's not in prison and his son still
lives with him then he goes nuts along
with every other animal themed character
in New York and turns his son into a
second lizard lizard' jr. if you will
this is ignored in a few of the
following stories a few appearances
later his son is in a foster home he's
trying to get custody of him and then
kidnaps him we see inner monologues from
curt and the lizard who is a separate
voice in his head which officially he
confirms everything from lizard's tail
and makes that whole story a pointless
mess but you can't say it's non-canon
and didn't happen because Billy Connors
was separated from his father after his
criminal charges and the lizard has
never been to jail before that because
Spidey always protected his identity and
brought him home after an episode what
I'm getting at here is that the lizard
is
a weird subsection of characters in
terms of popularity he's not important
enough that you can't you know make
drastic changes to him every once in a
while and do some experimental stuff but
he's too important to have those changes
be permanent because the general readers
all know the same basic idea of him sad
scientists involuntary transformation
into a monster his family is worried
about him he's not like moon night where
no one cares and every run completely
reinvents the character that's going to
change after the TV show comes out but
then in the same story entitled shed
lizards so riled up that he kills and
eats Billy Connors this is another big
moment where the character could be
changed forever Curt Connors is so
traumatized by this event that he
completely recedes into his own mind and
stays in some kind of humanoid
intelligent form of the lizard for
multiple storylines then he's back to
being Curt again then his son and wife
get revived his clones but they're
partially spliced with lizard DNA and
they look a little bit scaly and their
mutant people now and they live in the
sewers every third or fourth appearance
of the lizard the writers do something
drastic to the status quo of the
character in order to keep him
interesting but then over those two or
three appearances middle it's either
forgotten about or softly undone the
lizard like many Marvel characters is in
a weird paradoxical position where they
have to keep evolving to stay relevant
since casual fans do know about them but
they can't change too much or it'll
alienate those casual fans and become
confusing it's like when they killed off
Kraven the hunter only for him to be
revived via magic and then kill himself
again leaving behind a clone that's been
aged to his mid-20s so he's in his prime
and can just continue the legacy we had
this big important ending for the
character but now he's basically back
and it's like he never left the lizard
is stuck in an infinite loop and I can
guarantee he'll find a cure for his
family in one of his appearances soon
just so they can be right back at zero
again that family is so cursed with
being stuck in the same state that Billy
Connors is the only kid in spider-man
comics who has an
Aged Harry Osborn's son went from a
newborn baby to ten years old in the
same time it took Billy to go from ten
to thirteen he should be in his twenties
by this point even venom was able to
have a son that's now at least ten and
that too I can only guess is something
that won't stay around for long they'll
probably die or get adopted and
forgotten about for twenty years after
he served his purpose in this story
because the status quo for venom is not
a reporter with an alien parasite that's
also a dad I'd like to make a side note
that giving a violent antihero character
a random child they didn't know about to
force them to be more responsible is
happening way too often Deadpool has a
daughter Moon Knight as a dad now
I called that twist with Dylan Brock the
second I saw his face heck they even did
it in an issue of Punisher max a little
bit hey even the movie Logan did it it's
like everyone's allowed to be a dad
except spider-man and all of these cheap
character development bastard children
are disposable in temporary Deadpool
already forgot about is like like
literally forgot you use drugs to erase
his memory with any story that runs this
long you have to make changes to your
characters to keep them fresh and
interesting much like your long-running
TV series or webcomic it's a story that
can't have a definitive end so firm
conclusions are few and far between but
there's certainly exceptions to the rule
where long-form storytelling can embrace
a drastic change in status quo and make
it work some good examples from TV are
the good place which completely throws
its premise out the window after the
first season for a shocking twist and
just rolls with it or even that animated
show Archer where the secret agent
parody is running a little thin and the
fictional agency had a really
unfortunate name that realized
circumstances forced them to change so
they just take those same characters and
every season throw them somewhere new
and different and see what kind of
action and comedy comes of it comics
don't often do something like this and
big pot-stirring moments that alter the
story are used mostly to keep the sales
up instead of servicing said story it
gets readers invested when they learned
that the normal everyday life of their
favorite hero or villain is about to be
disrupted in a crazy way it makes
for some really great attention-grabbing
clickbait headlines or maybe a really
wacky cover for the issue that sells
particularly well but these major
changes don't stay for long they're an
easily reversible gimmick it takes an
insane amount of work care and
persistence to make any big character
growth stay that's not to say it never
happens the depressed loner Batman one
day decided to take on a warden
basically became the adoptive father of
a whole pantheon of kids meaning he's
not really as lonely as we all used to
think he is spider-man was even able to
grow up beyond his teenage superhero
schtick and is now a functional adult
who pays his own bills he was the
original teen superhero but for all
these other copycats granted both of
those examples happen in the 40s and 60s
before these characters became too
popular for their own good
I suppose Hank Pym isn't popular enough
to keep stagnant he's Ultron now and
that's been around for quite a while I
hope that sticks you could say it
happened with venom slowly but surely he
stopped being a poorly written edgy 90s
spider-man villain and started being a
sci-fi horror themed antihero that
Spidey considers a friend magneto is no
longer the violent terrorist
supervillain that he used to be and that
was a cherished ally and friend of the
x-men to honor the legacy of Professor X
who will come back to life as soon as
the Marvel Studios movie comes out and
magneto will become evil again because
brand synergy jeez I'm not helping my
point but it happens sometimes
yet in the case of characters like the
lizard you can't help but feel bad about
how it's always the same old problems on
repeat with brief intermissions of
something unique before it all snaps
back into place it's a special no-win
scenario for creatives when they're
making these characters because you run
the risk of breaking a character someone
else created decades ago and stamping on
their ideas or by making a change that's
so permanent in airtight that the next
guy feels creatively stifled because he
can't change it if you just write
whatever you want fans be damned it's
easy to completely alienate your
audience and destroy their interest in
the story if you write solely based on
whatever the fans want it turns into a
shallow mess of
and service and nostalgia baiting with
no clear direction I'm not sure what
solution there is here what position to
take because it's such a complicated
problem
lizards syndrome is a flaw that sort of
comes with the territory for this
creative medium though sometimes I see
example of lizard syndrome and other art
mediums where storytellers are so
pressured by massive almost religiously
devout phantoms that they have to play
it incredibly safe and try to keep the
series fresh by taking risks it's a
clumsy tightrope walk that if you can
make it across usually leaving this
middling effect where growth happens but
doesn't matter five minutes later take
Star Wars for example they pulled a
major plot twist in the second movie of
this new trilogy by killing off the main
villain completely throwing out
expectations of the series just
rehashing the old movies then that twist
left a very vocal set of fans feeling
dissatisfied and disappointed and
discouraged and disjointed disc and here
we are with a sequel to retcon Snoke
into being like just a puppet like a
literal meat puppet possessed by the fan
favorite villain who is behind
everything even though that makes zero
sense the fandom hated a major change so
the writers panicked and undid it making
the whole thing feel even less
satisfying I know a lot of people are up
in arms about the Palpatine situation
but this sort of thing happens on a
weekly basis if you're reading comic
books in fact this may as well have been
the ending of the Clone Saga where they
just said oh yeah Norman Osborn is
behind everything even though we killed
him off decades ago let's let's let's
wrap this up because we wrote ourselves
into a corner fans are nearly impossible
to please but that doesn't stop writers
from trying their best to do it anyway
with varying results I'd like to open up
the conversation to you the viewer and
ask what do you think would be the best
way to work around this lizard syndrome
problem so that both creators and the
fans can be happy while still letting
heroes and villains evolve organically
and try new things is there an answer to
this paradox well maybe you're a writer
Marvel listening to this and you've just
been inspired to try your own method
either way good ol Curt Connors is here
to stay and he's far from the worst case
of repetitive characters and comics but
a part of me does wish that the guy
could finally get a proper happy ending
[Music]
[Music]